we have some breaking news from the
labor department america's unemployment
rate is tied now for the lowest it's
been in more than 50 years now the rate
had been hovering around 3.6 percent for
the past four months well now it is down
to 3.5 where it was just before the
pandemic
job openings were also significantly up
month to month but there are some signs
that the economy may be starting to slow
down especially in the retail sector
chris van cleeve is covering it all
chris good morning
well good morning these job numbers it's
another opportunity for economists to
try to read the recession tea leaves
a slowing pace of hiring could be a sign
of a weakening labor market it could
also be a sign that big businesses have
essentially filled all of their
must-hire positions and are now easing
off additional hires but if you own
something like a restaurant you're
starting to get really worried that the
workers you need just aren't ever coming
back
ford's fish shack in loudoun county
virginia has no problem selling its fish
and chips more than 50 thousand pounds
of them last year alone but finding
enough workers remains a huge problem
it's tougher now than it was two years
ago a year ago you know even six months
ago owner tony stafford is now
considering closing one of his three
restaurants so the other two could be
fully staffed some nights we have to
close sections portions of the dining
room some hours were limiting now on
different parts of the week you think
this is a warning sign for the bigger
economy yeah and his costs are up about
a third as customers stung by gas prices
and inflation are starting to cut back
something's got to give and right now
we're seeing it being restaurants and
dining out the national federation of
independent business found small
business owners are more pessimistic
about future business conditions than at
any point in the survey's 48 year
history half reported job openings they
could not fill
and while some are hurting to fill jobs
others aren't making enough in the ones
they have this year we have done 400
percent more in financial assistance
than we did in say 2019. in alexandria
catholic charities program director
sherry longhill has seen demand for food
and emergency aid skyrocket the people
we're talking to they're saying that
they can get a part-time job they cannot
get full-time hours
and there's no benefits the work that's
out there isn't covering the bills
exactly
after having her hours cut at work
edelen vasquez came to christ house food
pantry to help feed her family how is
this economy treating you well right now
it's very bad because everything is very
expensive
that food pantry is seeing a 40 percent
increase in demand for food now low
unemployment is generally a good thing
but economists tell us in this case it
is likely helping drive inflation more
people are working that makes it a more
competitive labor market wages go up
prices go up people keep spending and
that's why many of the economists we've
talked to over the last couple of weeks
have said if we want inflation to go
down unemployment likely has to go up
david
we hear that loud and clear chris van
cleave ashburn virginia thank you